comienzan las deportaciones decenas de
haitianos fueron regresados a su país
este domingo desde texas en tres vuelos
que salieron desde las ciudades texanas
de san antonio y laredo rumbo a puerto
príncipe la capital haitiana las
autoridades estadounidenses fueron
enfáticas en que los migrantes
irregulares seguirán siendo regresados a
su país
los migrantes que intenten o estén
considerando hacer el viaje a nuestra
frontera deben saber que todavía estamos
haciendo cumplir la orden del título 42
y que no les permitirán ingresar a eeuu
serán expulsados y enviados de regreso a
su país de origen
el título 42 establece que los migrantes
pueden ser devueltos a su país sin pasar
por una audiencia con un juez el jefe de
patrulla anunció que al menos tres mil
300 migrantes ya han sido trasladados a
aviones oa centros de detención la
situación sigue siendo crítica en del
río donde según el alcalde de la ciudad
el sábado se refugiaban más de 14.800
personas
sin importar la llevamos de haití porque
no tiene seguridad
haití
son vendidos
tiene que es así bien todo el día
y así vivir con policía con bandera el
primer ministro haitiano manifestó su
preocupación por la situación de sus
coterráneos en eeuu al mismo tiempo que
renovamos nuestra plena solidaridad con
ellos queremos asegurarles que ya se han
hecho los arreglos para ofrecerles una
mejor acogida a su regreso al país y que
no se quedarán atrás los migrantes deben
ser deportados a su país que sigue
inmerso en una crisis política y
económica desde el asesinato de su
presidente rubén el mois